in the last video we started with the
transfer linear transformation s that
was a mapping between the set X that was
a subset of RN to the set Y and then we
had another transformation that was a
mapping from the set Y to the set Z we
asked ourselves given these two linear
transformations could we construct a
linear transformation that goes all the
way from X to Z and what we did is we
made a definition we said well let's
let's let's what let's create something
called the composition of T with s and
what that is is first you apply s to
some vector and X to get some vector and
Y and that's your vector right there and
then you apply T to that to get to Z and
so we defined it that way and our next
question was was that a linear
transformation we show that it was by it
met the two requirements for them and
because it is a linear transformation I
left off in the last video saying that
it should be able to be represented by
some matrix vector product where this
will have to be an L by n matrix because
it's a mapping from an n dimensional
space which was X it was a member of our
it was a subset of RN to an L
dimensional space because Z is a subset
of our L now in this video let's try to
actually construct this matrix so at the
beginning of laughs of the last video I
wrote told you that T of X could be
written as some matrix product B times X
let me write that let me write it
rewrite it down here so I told you that
the linear transformation T applied to
some vector X could be written as the
matrix vector product B times the vector
X and since it was a mapping from a from
a M dimensional space to an L
dimensional space we know that this is
going to be an L by M L by M matrix now
similarly I told you that the
transformation s can also be written as
a matrix vector product where we could
say maybe a is its matrix representation
times the vector X and since this is a
mapping from a
Burress was a mapping from a
n-dimensional space to an M dimensional
space this will be an M by n matrix M by
n matrix now by definition what was the
composition of T of s T with s what is
this by definition we said this is equal
to you first apply the transform the
linear transformation s to X and I'll
arbitrarily switch colors so you first
apply the transformation s to X and that
essentially gets you into get to a
vector right there
right this is just a vector in RM or
it's really a vector in Y which is
subset of RM and then you apply the
transformation T to that vector to get
you into Z so then you apply T to that
you apply T to that well given this we
can use our matrix representations to
replace this kind of transformation
representation all the really the same
thing what is the transformation of s
applied to X well it's just this right
here is just a times X that is just a
times X where this is an M by n M by n
matrix so we could say that this is
equal to the transformation applied to a
times X now what is the transformation
of what is the T transformation applied
to any vector X well that's the matrix B
times your vector X so this thing right
here is going to be equal to B times
whatever I put in there so the the
matrix B times the matrix a times the
vector X right there this is what our
composition transformation is are the
composition of T with s applied to the
vector X which takes us from the set X
all the way to the set Z is this if we
use the matrix forms of the two
transformations now we know that we can
you know at the end of last video I said
I wanted to find a I wanted to find just
some matrix that if I multiply it times
vector that is equivalent to this
transformation and I know that I can
find this matrix I know that this is
exist because this is a linear
transformation so how can we do that
well we just do what we've always done
in the past we find we start with the
identity matrix and we apply the
transformation to every column of the
identity matrix and then you end up with
your matrix representation of the
transformation itself so first of all
how big is the identity matrix going to
be well these guys that were inputting
into our transformation they are subsets
of X or they're members of X which are
an n dimensional space it's a subset of
RN so these let me write this X is a
member of our n so all we do to figure
out C is we apply so we start off with
the identity matrix so let's see we
start with the identity matrix the
n-dimensional identity matrix because
we're starting our domain is RN and of
course we know what that looks like we
draw a little straighter we have 1 0 all
the way down it's going to be an N by n
matrix and then 0 1 all the way down
zeros these are zeros right here and
then you have ones go all the way down
the columns and everything else
everything else is 0 we've seen this
multiple times that's what your identity
matrix looks like just ones down the
column from the top left to the bottom
right now to figure out C to figure out
C the matrix representation of our
transformation we all we do is we apply
the transformation to each of these
columns so we can write we can write
that our matrix C is equal to it's going
to take some space here the
transformation applied to this first
column but what is the transformation it
is the matrix B it's the matrix B times
the matrix a times whatever you're
taking the transformation of in this
case we're taking the transformation of
that so we're taking the transformation
of 1 0 0 all the way down there's much
as 0s 1 followed by a bunch of zeros
that's going to be our first column of C
our second column of C is going to be B
times a
times the second column of our identity
matrix and of course you remember these
are each the standard basis vectors for
RN so this is e 1 2 vector e 2 I could
actually put a hat there because their
unit vectors but you know that already
so this is going to be times e 2 which
is 0 1 0 all the way down bunch of zeros
and then we're going to keep doing that
until we do get to the last column which
is B times a times a bunch of zeros all
the way down and you get a 1 the nth
term is just a 1 right there now what is
this going to be equal to I mean it
looks fairly complicated right now but
all you have to do is make the
realization and we've seen this multiple
times that look if we write our vector a
or we're at our matrix a is just a bunch
of column vectors so this is a column
vector a1 a2 all the way to a n right we
already learned that this was an N by M
matrix n by M matrix then what is the
vector a times for example 1 well
actually let me write it this way times
x1 x2 all the way down to xn we've seen
this multiple times this is equivalent
to this is equivalent to x1 times a1
plus x2 times a2 all the way to plus X n
times a n we've seen this multiple times
it's a linear combination of these
column vectors where the weighting
factors are the terms and our vector
that we're taking the product of so
given that what is this guy going to
reduce to this is going to be a 1 times
this first entry right here times x1
plus a2 times the second entry plus a3
times the third entry but all of these
other entries are 0 the X 2's all the
way to the xn are 0 so it's only you're
only going to end up with 1 times the
first column here an a so this will
reduce to let me write this so C will be
equal to
the first column is going to be B times
now a times this this e 1 vector I guess
we can call it the standard basis vector
right there we already said it's just
going to be 1 times the first column in
a plus 0 times the second common a plus
0 times the third column and so on and
so forth so it's just 1 times the first
column in a so it's just a 1 that's
simple
now what is this one going to be equal
to well it's going to be 0 times the
first column in a 0 times the first
column in a plus 1 times the second
column in a plus 0 times the third
common a and the rest are going to be 0
so it's just going to be 1 times the
second column in a so this one second
column in our transformation matrix it's
just going to be B times a 2 and I think
you get the idea here each of these the
next one's going to be B times a 3 and
all the way till you get B times a and
all the way until you get B times a and
and so that's how you would solve for
your transformation matrix remember what
we were trying to do we were trying to
find some let me write out kind of
summarize everything that we've done so
far we had a mapping s that was a
mapping from X to Y but X was a subset
of RN Y was a subset of RM and so we
said this transformation this linear
transformation could be represented as
some matrix a where a is a M by n matrix
times a vector X then we I showed you
another transformation let's call that
well we already called it T which was a
mapping from Y to Z Z is a subset of RL
Z is a subset of RL and of course T the
transformation T applied to some vector
and X and sorry in Y can be represented
as some matrix B times that vector times
that vector I should have drawn
parentheses there but you get the idea
and this since it's a mapping from a
subset of RM to RL this will be an L by
M matrix and then we said look if we
actually just take the definition of if
we take the composition of T with s this
reduced to of some vector in X this
reduced to B so first we applied the S
transformation so we multiplied the
matrix a times X we multiply the matrix
a times X and then we apply the T
transformation to this so we just
multiply B times that we've multiplied B
times that now we know that this is a
linear transformation which means it can
be represented as a matrix vector
product and we just figured out what the
matrix vector product is so this thing
is going to be equal to this is
equivalent to switch colors C times X
which is equal to which is equal to this
thing right there which is equal to that
thing right there which is equal to let
me write it this way B be a 1 I'll try
to be true to the colors be a 1 where a
1 is the first column vector in our
matrix a and then the second column here
is going to be B and then we have a 2
where this is the second column vector
in a and then you could keep going all
the way until you have B times a n a n
right there at times X of course times X
let me make it maybe make it purple
times X like that
now this is fair enough we can always do
this we can if you give me some matrix
remember this is an L by M matrix L by M
matrix and you give me another matrix
right here that is a M by n matrix M by
n matrix I can always do this and how do
I know I can always do that because how
many entries are each of these each of
these A's are going to have M entries
right they're going to be they're going
to be
a 1 I say AI all of them are going to be
members of RM so this is well-defined
this has m columns this has m entries so
each of these matrix vector products are
well-defined now this is an interesting
thing because I mean we were able to
figure out the actual matrix
representation of this composition
transformation but let's let's extend it
a little bit further wouldn't it be nice
if this were the same thing as the
matrices B times a wouldn't this be nice
if this were the same things as the
matrix B times I don't want to write
problem you start B times a all of that
times X all of that times X wouldn't it
be nice if these were the same thing
because then we could say that the
composition of T with s of X is equal to
the matrix representation of B times the
matrix representation of s and you take
the product of those two and then that
will create a new matrix representation
that you can which you could call C that
you can then multiply times X so you
won't have to do it you know
individually every time or do it this
way and I guess the the truth of the
matter is there is nothing to stop us
from defining this to be equal to B
times a we have not defined what a
matrix times a matrix is yet so we might
as well this is good enough motivation
for us to define it in this way so let's
throw in this definition let us define
let us define so if we have some matrix
B and we could well I don't have to draw
what it looks like but B is a B is a L
by M matrix and then we have some other
matrix a and I'll actually show what a
looks like where these are its column
vectors a1 a2 all the way to a n and
then we are going to define the product
so this is a definition this is a
definition we're going to define the
product ba as being equal to the matrix
B times each of the column vectors of a
so it's B
e times a 1 that's going to be its first
column this is going to be B times a 2
all the way to B times a n and you've
seen this before in algebra 2 but the
reason why I did when I went through
kind of almost 2 videos to get to here
is to show you the motivation for why
matrices matrix matrix products are
defined this way because it makes the
notion of compositions of
transformations kind of natural if you
take the composition of one trend linear
transformation with another the
resulting transformation matrix is just
the product as we've just defined it of
their two transformation matrices now
for those of you who you know might not
have a lot of experience taking products
of matrices and who think this is fairly
abstract to look at in the next video
I'll actually do a bunch of examples and
show you that this definition is
actually fairly straightforward